[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
hollweg guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann steht
und auch familie und das sind einige
unsere themen heute
boostern gegen die vierte corona welle
die gesundheitsminister wollen
auffrischimpfungen für alle
proteste in glasgow die aktivisten von
friedrichs for future fordern vom
weltklimagipfel mehr tempel und
konkretere zusagen
und eine der letzten überlebenden des
holocaust wird 100 margot friedländer
erzählt von den schrecken der nazi
herrschaft
in der pandemie stehen sehr schwere
wochen bevor das prophezeit
gesundheitsminister sparen zum abschluss
der zweitägigen beratungen mit seinen
kollegen und kolleginnen aus den
bundesländern die lage sei
besorgniserregend
der blick auf den verlauf der pandemie
seit anfang 2000 20 zeigt seit gut drei
wochen erleben wir die mittlerweile
vierte infektionswelle heute mit
37.000 120 neue infektionen so viele wie
noch nie an einem tag die
gesundheitsminister wollen gegensteuern
mit einer booster impfung für alle die
wollen nach sechs monaten eine
testpflicht für alten und pflegeheime
und in besonders betroffenen regionen
dürfen nur noch genesene und geimpfte zu
veranstaltungen alexander pohl berichtet
angesichts immer weiter steigender
infektionszahlen zeigen sich die
gesundheitsminister besorgt und
nachdenklich allen voran jens spahn der
noch amtierende
bundesgesundheitsminister spricht von
der vierten pandemiewelle die gerade
erst begonnen habe wir merken aber jetzt
dass diese vierte welle mit voller wucht
kommt dass sie deutlich an fahrt
aufgenommen hat vor uns liegen sehr
schwere wochen das zeichnet sich allein
schon durch die hohen infektionszahlen
ab der weg durch diese schwierigen
wochen führt darin ist sich die runde
einig auch über die so genannten booster
impfungen die sollten zur regel werden
wichtig ist die botschaft
das auffrischungsimpfungen vom grundsatz
nach sechs monaten für alle möglich sein
sollen insbesondere natürlich für die
gruppen medizinisches personal ältere
menschen aber wir wollen damit ganz
stark in diese welle reingehen die
forderung nach strengeren corona
maßnahmen im alltag wird lauter im
schwer betroffenen sachsen etwa gilt ab
montag die zweijährige etwa in
restaurants
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen kann
sich dass grundsätzlich auch in anderen
brennpunkten vorstellen dass zwei
geimpft und genesen in bestimmten lagen
hohe infektionszahlen hohe belastung
gesundheitswesens daneben auch regelhaft
eine option sein soll für die
zugangsbeschränkung zu bestimmten
veranstaltungen restaurants und anderes
mehr geeinigt hat man sich außerdem auf
verpflichtende corona tests in alten und
pflegeheimen für das personal geimpfte
und genießen da wird der bund die
voraussetzungen auch schaffen dass dies
möglich ist und dass auch besucher dann
eben nicht gehindert werden wollen wir
dass diese tests auch in diesem bereich
kostenfrei zur verfügung gestellt werden
eine impfpflicht für pflegepersonal
dagegen lehnten die versammelten
gesundheitsminister heute erneut amten
stefan leifert in lindow gibt es denn
jetzt klare bundesweit einheitliche
kriterien was ab welchem wert gilt
nein und das ist die große regelungs
lehrstelle die nach der konferenz hier
in lindern und bleiben wird zum einen
weil den gesundheitsministern
schlichtweg die kompetenz fehlt und das
zu regeln zum anderen aber auch weil die
politik ziemlich lange finger hat wenn
es um das thema geht ungeimpfte aus dem
öffentlichen leben auszuschließen
sachsen soll sich heute als erstes
bundesland gezwungen flächendeckend
zweijährigen einzuführen aufgrund der
dramatischen corona zahlen andere länder
könnten nun folgen und damit daraus
jetzt nicht das große regel chaos in
deutschland wird wurden hier heute auch
in linda forderungen laut nach einer
möglichst baldigen
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz in berlin
das ziel einer solchen veranstaltung
soll dann sein möglichst schnell
einheitliche bundesweite kriterien
vorzulegen wann unter welchen kriterien
und wo zweig regeln gelten sollen also
diese konferenz hier in lindau hat auch
gezeigt dass der korona krisenmodus mit
voller wucht in der politik zurück ist
danke nach dem tausch davon leifert war
das
booster impfungen gegen die vierte welle
alle die vollständig geimpft sind wir
haben es gehört sollen die möglichkeit
bekommen nach sechs monaten noch mal
nachzulegen wenn sie wollen aber was
bringt diese booster impfung warum ist
sie wichtig thomas garcia hat details
boostern auffrischen nochmals impfen wie
immer man es nennt es hilft sagen
experten denn immunologisch wird durch
diese booster impfung die immunität noch
mal deutlich verstärkt dann wird
sozusagen super ihm um ein super schutz
der so funktioniert nach impfungen
werden antikörper aufgebaut und so
genannte gedächtniszellen kommt eine
neue impfung erinnern sich die an die
vergangene dosis und starten eine
schnellere und stärkere reaktion der
booster macht drei dinge er macht höhere
antiker bei spiegel deshalb bin ich
besser geschützt er macht auch bessere
antikörper deshalb bin ich auch
spezifischer geschützt und er macht auch
mehr gedächtniszellen und deshalb habe
ich auch einen immunschutz der länger
anhält bessern und spezifischer
geschützt das bestätigen israelische
studien ihnen zufolge haben menschen mit
booster einen zehnmal höheren schutz vor
corona infektionen als zweifach geimpft
und einen zehn- bis zwanzigmal hören vor
schweren verläufen länger geschützt dazu
fehlen noch studien aber die erfahrung
spreche dafür dass der schuss vor der
rhein infektion deutlich länger als ein
halbes jahr hält und auch gerade der
schuss von der schweren erkrankung
wahrscheinlich jetzt mehrere jahre
halten könnte übrigens auch bei
genesenen zweimal impfen reiche
besonders aber ältere sollten boostern
so forscher der charité nach sechs
monaten hätten fast die hälfte der über
70-jährigen keine oder kaum noch und die
körper und deswegen ganz dringen die
empfehlungen die sollen sich auffrischen
lassen müssen er genau die menschen die
das höchste risiko tragen das risiko
minimieren für sich und für andere auch
das betonen experten
postet oder wie immer man es nennen will
der hilft dass sich das virus weniger
verbreitet
auch ein neues medikament weckt
hoffnungen im kampf gegen korona die
pille mit dem namen pak slowik habe sich
in einer klinischen studie als hoch
wirksam erwiesen meldet der us
pharmariese pfizer das risiko wegen
krone ins krankenhaus zu müssen oder zu
sterben sei bei erwachsenen um knapp 90
prozent verringert offiziell zugelassen
ist das mittel noch nicht aus den usa
claudia bates
das medikament von pfizer könnte leben
retten und die krankenhäuser erheblich
entlasten die studie mit rund 1200
patienten sei wegen der klaren datenlage
vorzeitig beendet worden weniger als ein
prozent der patienten musste ins
krankenhaus keiner von ihnen starb die
studienteilnehmer waren nicht geimpft
und genau hier sieht weiser den nutzen
die intensivstationen sind überfüllt mit
menschen die sich leider infiziert haben
dafür haben wir eine lösung hier passt
es das medikament verhindert nicht die
infektion sondern es behandelt
diejenigen die sich leider angesteckt
haben
die studienergebnisse sind noch nicht
unabhängig wissenschaftlich geprüft das
muss noch erfolgen experten sind
optimistisch betonen aber weiterhin die
bedeutung der impfung
das beste ist sich impfen zu lassen oder
eine infektion von vornherein zu
vermeiden die pillen sind nützlich aber
prävention ist immer besser als
behandlung bei jeder krankheit
nun soll rasch die zulassung in den usa
beantragt werden und die regierung will
dann nicht zögern
wenn die behörde das medikament zulässt
dann könnten wir bald pillen zur
behandlung der kranken haben wir haben
uns schon millionen von dosen gesichert
pfizer konkurrent merck hat für sein
cockpit medikament bereits gestern die
zulassung in großbritannien erhalten es
ist weniger wirksam aber beide
medikamente wären weitere bausteine im
kampf gegen die pandemie
zurück nach deutschland von den
koalitionsverhandlungen dringt noch
immer so gut wie nichts nach außen
vertraulichkeit wurde vereinbart ein
kurzes update gab es aber heute von
grünen-chefin baerbock wir sind noch
nicht so weit erklärte sie seit fast
zwei wochen laufen die gespräche
zwischen spd grünen und fdp nun laut
baerbock hakt es bei zentralen
baustellen wie der klimapolitik dabei
soll eigentlich in der nikolaus woche
olaf scholz zum kanzler gewählt werden
fragen wir chacon talabani in berlin ist
das taktik der grünen oder wackelt der
zeitplan
wahrscheinlich von beidem etwas
tatsächlich ist dieser zeitplan ja so
eng gestrickt dass er sofort wackelt
wenn auch nur eine der 22 arbeitsgruppen
etwas länger bei einer frage braucht als
es vorgesehen ist nach dem strengen
stundenplanung genau das scheint jetzt
zur zeit so passieren wenn man den
grünen glaubt die sich ja darüber
beschweren dass das beim thema verkehr
nicht so richtig weiter geht das spielt
beim klimaschutz eine große rolle und da
gehen bekanntlich die vorstellungen
darüber was man machen könnte um mehr
co2 einzusparen und das auch schneller
einzusparen weit auseinander auf der
anderen seite muss man aber auch sagen
dass das natürlich ein klassischer
taktischer schachzug in
koalitionsverhandlungen ist anzudeuten
wo man noch unzufrieden ist und in dem
fall ist es natürlich ein gutes
druckmittel zu sagen oder brauchen wir
wahrscheinlich noch länger denn dann
kommt der ganze zeitplan ins rutschen
wenn es bis zur nikolaus woche klappen
soll mit der kanzlerwahl müssen eben
alle gas geben und dass jetzt die
anderen jetzt auch unter druck die
einschätzung unserer hauptstadt
korrespondent in vielen dank herr gunter
lange
noch von der amtierenden regierung
beschlossen die neue
heizkostenverordnung heute gab der
bundesrat grünes licht damit erübrigt
sich bald das jährliche ablesen des
zählerstand vor ort neu installierte
zähler müssen aus der ferne ablesbar
sein alte geräte sollten bis ende 2026
ausgetauscht werden auf der dann
monatlichen rechnung unter anderem auch
ein vergleich mit dem vormonat das soll
zum energiesparen anregen der deutsche
mieterbund fürchtet zusätzliche kosten
für die mieter
die erwartungen an den klimagipfel in
glasgow sind hoch vor allem bei
klimaschützern statt leerer versprechen
fordern sie konkrete zusagen
aktivisten versammelten sich heute
weltweit auf den straßen wie zum
beispiel hier in bonn auch in polen gab
es proteste und fast am anderen ende der
welt in indonesien in glasgow selbst
zogen mit fridays for future tausende
durch die stadt diana zimmermann
berichtet
es ist der tag der jugend in glasgow und
sie ist nicht zufrieden mit dem was die
klimakonferenz bisher geleistet hat
tatsächlich verfehlen die angekündigten
maßnahmen das ziel die erderwärmung
unter 1,5 grad zu halten auch fühlen
sich die jungen nicht ausreichend
repräsentiert greta thunberg etwa wird
auf der konferenz nicht sprechen hier
ist sie der star
ist eine werbeveranstaltung geworden bei
der politiker wunderschöne reden halten
und tolle ziele versprechen während die
regierungen der nördlichen länder sich
hinter verschlossenen türen immer noch
weigern irgend etwas drastisches für das
klima zu tun
doch es gibt auch viel optimismus
hier sind abertausende von leuten die
alle was verändern wollen und wenn so
viele kommen aus dem ganzen land dann
können wir natürlich was bewegen
und bewegen wollen sie nicht nur mit
kritik von außen hunderte der jungen
nehmen an der konferenz teil einige sind
als beobachter der offiziellen
verhandlungen zugelassen andere machen
in arbeitsgruppen druck auf die
mächtigen schon in deutschland also die
flutkatastrophe die solche extreme
wetterereignisse werden viel häufiger
mit der klimakrise und man spürt es auf
der ganzen welt des lebensgefährlich
jetzt und das muss hier
endlich anerkannt werden heute
überreichte die jugendorganisation mango
dem un-generalsekretär ihren
forderungskatalog verfasst von 40.000
unter 30 jährigen aus der ganzen welt
getrieben vom wissen darum dass sie auf
dieser erde noch lange zu leben und
deshalb wenig zeit zu verlieren haben
seit sechs wochen schon brodelt auf der
kanaren insel la palma der vulkan die
einwohner nennen ihn inzwischen das
biest die lavaströme haben bereits mehr
als 2700 gebäude zerstört oder
beschädigt etwa 8000 hektar gelten als
sperrbezirk vulkan asche regnet wie
schwarzer schnee herunter und raubt den
bewohnern gärten und felder zum teil
sind die ascheberger meter hoch von der
insel berichtet christel hass
plötzlich wird es dunkel eine dicke
rauchwolke schiebt sich vor die sonne
der vulkan ein albtraum seit einer
gefühlten ewigkeit so empfinden es alle
die hier leben jeden tag kehren sie
asche die überall zentimeter hoch liegt
doch nur wenige stunden später ist alles
wieder schwarz bei kirsten und thorsten
niemand gibt es nichts mehr zu klären
die lava hat ihr haus und ihre
ferienwohnungen vernichtet sie lagen
direkt unterhalb des vulkans das ist das
foto ihres verlustes ihr heim stand
zwischen den beiden roten gebäuden
claver zerstörte alles da es ist nichts
mehr aufzuräumen ist es nichts mehr
aufzubauen sondern es ist alles
komplettes ist dort natürlich nichts
mehr zu retten ununterbrochen wälzt sich
neue lover talabwärts türmt sich auf der
bereits vorhandenen schicht auf
insgesamt gibt es zehn ströme unter
ständiger beobachtung ist immer auch die
schadstoffbelastung die schwefeldioxid
werte sind seit gestern gesunken sorgen
macht aber die asche in der luft die
schulen bleiben deshalb geschlossen die
anwohner sollen sich möglichst wenig im
freien aufhalten schrank disco kann
nicht drinnen bleiben er muss sich um
seine bananenplantage kümmern auch hier
ist alles voller asche die hälfte der
ernte ist verloren
feuer lava und ein himmel voller asche
seit fast sieben wochen und nichts
deutet auf ein schnelles ende hin
jetzt zu einer tief beeindruckenden frau
margot friedländer überlebte den
holocaust sie fasste fuß in den usa und
kehrte dann zurück nach deutschland um
vor allem auch an schulen ihre
geschichte zu erzählen als nicola
albrecht sie jetzt zu ihrem 100
geburtstag um ein interview bat da
lehnte sie erst ab weil alles gerade ein
bisschen viel wäre kurz danach rief sie
zurück und sagte wenn sie den
geburtstagsempfang schafft dann auch das
interview
pausen gönnt sich margot friedländer
auch mit 100 kaum die zeit die sie sich
nimmt ist ihr geschenk an uns alle immer
und immer wieder erzählt sie ihre
geschichte geht an schulen beantwortet
fragen in corona zeiten auch ganz locker
digital das ist was ich euch
seid vorsichtig wählt richtig die
demokratie ist wichtig seit menschen
akzeptiert andere menschen ganz egal
welche religion welche hautfarbe sie
haben
margot friedländer familie wurde in
auschwitz ermordet sie selbst überlebte
das kz theresienstadt wanderte nach der
befreiung in die usa aus und wagt im
alter von 88 jahren einen neuanfang
zieht nach berlin zurück ins land der
täter ich bin zurückgekommen um mit euch
zu sprechen
euch die hand zu reichen
es gibt mir auch kraft weil ihr mich
anhört verrückte zeiten seien es auch
heute meint margot friedländer aber sie
sei voller hoffnung und so haben wir uns
wieder verabredet spätestens zum 100 und
erst
ja aber weiter zuerst mal ihren
hundertsten gefeiert mit 100 gästen wir
gratulieren volle bewunderung und kommen
jetzt zu europa fußball lebt mit einem
erfolgreichen abend für die deutschen
teams leverkusen mit einem
hochverdienten 4 10 0-heimsieg gegen
betis sevilla ein hartes stück arbeit
dagegen für die eintracht 2 2 1 bei
olympiakos piräus ein frankfurter last
minute entschied das spiel im
hexenkessel von athen
die effektiven streckübungen des kevin
trapp haben großen anteil am erfolg
frankfurts keeper hat letztlich nur
einmal das nachsehen
in der zwölften minute ist es der pass
von only kourou den el arabi zum eins zu
null für piräus nutzt nur fünf minuten
später gelingt den hessen der ausgleich
beim griechischen rekordmeister die
kamera eins zu eins in der nachspielzeit
demonstrieren die frankfurter erneut
ihren kampfgeist der siegtreffer von
jens-peter auge der norweger übrigens
eine leihgabe vom ac mailand unterm
strich kein rundum perfektes spiel aber
ein top-ergebnis
union berlin dagegen mit einer
heimniederlage in der konferenz ligue 1
2 gegen vier nord rotterdam die eisernen
haben aber noch chancen aufs
weiterkommen
bundestrainer hansi flick hat den kader
für die wm qualifikationsspiele nächste
woche gegen liechtenstein und armenien
nominiert erstmals in der dfb auswahl
wolfsburg 22 jährige stürmertalent lukas
matcher ja und jetzt noch der blick auf
morgen und auf das spitzenspiel in der
fußball bundesliga
der bislang ungeschlagene sc freiburg
muss zum tabellenführer nach münchen
christian streich vor dem 310
bundesligaspiele als freiburger trainer
nur drei punkte hinter bayern da kann
man sich was zuzutrauen es ist nicht so
dass mir nach nun erfahre und sage und
es war nie so mehr wolle
schadensbegrenzung
sondern der rolle hinter die stirn biete
aber wenn unsere stirn
vielleicht nur halb so große schwere die
bayern nach dem pokal aus wieder in
gewohnter form machen sich auf einen
recht ebenbürtigen gegner gefasst wir
wollen ihre erfolgreichen ersten zehn
spieltagen auch weiterführen und am ende
haben jetzt keine acht-punkte-vorsprung
vor ihnen und deswegen ist es ein
wichtiges spiel nagelsmann erlebnis
wieder auf der bank nach seiner krone
erkrankung kehrt in die bundesliga
zurück und
freiburgs trainer christian streich
morgen abend zu gast im aktuellen
sportstudio so um 23 uhr 30 hänge von
wetten dass
und vielleicht apropos wetten dass
elektrisiert dich das ja auch ganze 40
jahre gab es nichts neues von aber und
jetzt überraschung ein neues album
[Musik]
vielleicht ist der bewährte aber sound
der 70er fast 400 millionen platten
haben die schweden verkauft und das
comeback von den vieren die immerhin
schon über 70 sind klingt so
[Applaus]
wie gesehen
nein
morgen sind sie übrigens bei wetten dass
zumindest die männliche hälfte von abba
das wochenende wird eher trüb für einige
bringt es auch regen und wind für andere
sonne details hat gleich katja honnefer
claus kleber freut sich auf sie im heute
journal um 10 und wir freuen uns wenn
sie die augen wieder dabei sind ich
wünsche ihnen ein schönes wochenende auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend ganz streng genommen ist es
nicht das hoch sylvie sondern nur ein
ableger von hoch sylvie die uns morgen
in süddeutschland beehrt und am sonntag
schon gleich richtung westen wieder ab
düst denn am sonntag kommen neue
regenwolken hier von morgen heran und
die erreichen bis zum sonntagabend auch
süddeutschland heute nacht regnet es
etwas an den küsten von nord- und ostsee
und auch in schleswig holstein
im süden ist es häufig klar dass bildet
sich auch mal nebel so sind die
temperaturen ganz unterschiedlich
südlich von mosel und main sinken sie
auf plus 3 bis minus 5 grad am boden
wird es dann frostig im norden dagegen
liegen die werte unter dem dichten
regenwolken nur super 9 bis 7 grad
bleibt also deutlich milder tagsüber
ändert sich ja diesen werten allerdings
kaum was da sie das so 9 bis 11 grad im
süden allerdings wird es deutlich milder
als in der nacht ist mit fünf bis zehn
grad in süddeutschland geht es entweder
strahlenden sonnenschein vor allen
dingen am alpenrand auf den berggipfeln
sonst halten sich nebelfelder auch mal c
in der mitte ist es mal mehr mal weniger
stark bewölkt und in norddeutschland ist
es meist bedeckt und an den küsten fällt
noch etwas regen
am sonntag zieht dann neuer regen auf
und hinter diesen regenwolken gibt es
kräftige schauer und gewitter beim
starken bis stürmischen westwind im
süden ändert sich wenig guten abend